everybody else is focused on making the
project
the ad is focused on everybody making
the project
see the difference
you have a special approach the way you
look at production or screenwriting
part of it is is that and i've learned
this and i think i've got to be able to
articulate it through working with jeff
gordon at writer's boot camp was is the
idea that his tools that he designed
were ultimately designed if you used all
of them
to be able to give yourself a full 360
view of a project
so one of the things that i felt and
when i look at especially the production
process and prepping for production is
is it how many times can i circle a
project how many times can i look at it
in a different way
because if i can look at it in those
different ways then i can be prepared
for all of the things we were talking
about these scenarios that can go wrong
i can prepare for those scenarios
because i've looked at it and there's
different ways so if i fall behind i
know what my
plane is
if you know if i you know if we have to
cut some scenes we've already talked
about the scenes that we need to cut
right so anything that i can do to
anticipate the possibility of something
going wrong
and plan for it
then the likelihood of something that i
didn't plan for the more likely i will
be prepared for because i've eliminated
all of those other things
right
and if i think that i've gotten
everything figured out well that means i
probably haven't but it's just that idea
of
every time i do a shot list with the
director and we do it in a different
program
and we go through the list and we think
of it a different way and then i go and
i sit with the effects guy and i ask him
how is he going to do it and then i ask
the production manager how they're going
to do it and then i take all that
information i bring them all together
again and then ask them how they're
going to do it
that's how
you get cohesion that's how you get a
unit and that's how you get everybody on
the same page and that's also as an
individual
how i become a master of the material
even if i didn't write the material
right because now i may know the
material on some level better than the
writer does because i've broken it down
in different ways
so yeah that's the 360 theory of
production in writing
sure how many times are you usually
circling the screenplay in terms of
before you even get it to some of the
production well like you know like as a
writer for me it depends like i've
written you know half hour pilot things
where i've only had a week to write it
so i've circled it
once because i got it written right
um or something like zebra what i've
been working on for years and years and
years
you know i've probably circled it you
know
six or seven maybe ten times where i've
written
broken it down tried to do something new
and then gone back all the way through
the process again even slashed my
favorite things and now i'm doing it
again
um you know just a new having new ideas
because that's the key is if you're
willing to eliminate things it was the
worst thing in the world if you like cut
something out of script then you have no
idea what to put in it
right because you don't have any new
ideas to to
entertain that part of it or to fix that
to have a solution or to come around to
it
that's part of what screenwriting and
production are ultimately it's it's
it's problem-solving right it's it's
solutions and it's it's also creating
problems for characters and solving
problems for you
and why work 10 years on something
um
to become a better become a good enough
writer to be able to handle the material
and know that i wasn't willing to let it
go to somebody else but also it's also
because it's historical some of the
material wasn't available either
like documentation what i had to
actually research and learn about it so
as that grew i've been able to get
further along on it um that's why i'm
like in the next you know it has to be
done in the next
six months now and sean we'll see if i
don't get distracted
i get distracted i get distracted with
other people's things and i'm 110 type
of person so
it'll be hard for me to write something
for you if i've got a you know do a call
sheet tomorrow you know so it's kind of
those types of things too
what do most people think is a
producer's job and in fact it really
entails something very different
it's an interesting very very very
interesting question i've had a lot of
thoughts about it and
my view of what a producer is is someone
who actually is
the
as the director is the head of the
artistic side of the production the
producer is the head of everything else
and how that comes together how that can
come together depends on the scope of
the producer
a producer like myself i think can
influence
the mood and feeling and tone of the
entire production by just
simple selection of what the call sheet
is or simple selection of what the food
is or
simple communicate how they choose to
communicate with their staff or how they
handle problems
right so
if you're someone that is there to
communicate and is there to actually be
an agent to
to
i don't know amplify
what's already being done that you
really that you know that the the really
no one's really going to care about how
hard it was to make it all they're going
to care about is how good it is
but all of those things to get it to
that point people need to feel good to
do good things so if you don't put them
in a position
to do their best
their absolute best at all moments in
all times you're failing as a producer
if they don't have
the time if they don't have without a
conversation if if i tell you that
you're not going to have the time and
you still decide that you want to do it
that way and you make the decision as a
director to do it that way then we've
had a conversation but you got to have
that conversation
and you got to be able to have the
difficult conversations and you've got
to be able to make decisions like firing
people
and not be worried about it
you know the movie is the most important
thing and if the movie's the most
important thing you're doing that
genuinely from your heart then you will
do it with the best intentions and you
will do it with the best for the people
are on that set
and for the people and for the people
who are actually going to see that movie
so being a producer in a lot of ways is
um communication
i think it's all communication all
communication i think it really is it's
it's
it's
it's all communication essentially i
think it's being the communicator i
think on some levels being the
communicator not the communicator not
the director is a communicator for the
artists
the producer is a communicator for
everybody
and the director can say the production
designer blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah and then but the caterer doesn't
care about that the caterer just needs
to know where they want to put it and
whatever and if people seem to happy
around them
you know so they're not everybody on the
set's following the director but
everybody on the set is following the
producer
what do you see a lot of first-time
producers get wrong
it's much more important to
be
and be doing the things that need to be
done to help your production than
looking like you're doing the things
that
make your production redone
in other words
you know if if i really need you know
an extra person to run back and forth
between here in the dressing room that's
what i really need i don't need you know
a bts crew you know if we need
b
you know or if or understanding what the
priority is at the moment
you know a lot of
about a set is
and this is something we didn't get to
talk about but i think that the reason
one of the reasons i'm very passionate
about production in so many different
ways is also because of having been a
first ad
because a first ad
gets to
everybody else is focused on making the
project
the aed is focused on everybody making
the project
see the difference
that all those people and what they're
doing like being in the eye of the storm
on the set when you're just literally in
that position where you're watching
everybody else do what they're doing and
making sure they're not tripping over
things and no one's yelling over
somebody and everybody's going over and
the dp can it can talk to the you know
everybody just can hear each other it's
not too noisy and
are we getting things done and then
getting to that point are we ready to
take that shot and listening to
everybody making sure that they're in
creating that rhythm
that rhythm
is
a heartbeat
and the faster and the better you get
that then everybody just listens to that
heartbeat they don't listen to what's
going on in their heads they don't care
about what's going on they just focus on
what they're doing
and when they can walk out and they can
have a good meal and they can whatever
and they can joke and laugh and they go
back in and they're not distracted again
you're gonna get the best work and if
you don't and if you don't keep them
there for 13 14 16 crazy hours i also
don't work more than usually don't shoot
more than 10 to 11. 12-hour days are
unusual for us
we don't like to do that you know we
want to shoot i'd like to shoot tens you
know you're shooting 10 maybe it's a
12-hour day but you're really shooting
10 hours
you know so it's it's because you're
more efficient that way and it's not
necessarily you have to do one take
because i don't necessarily have to do
that but those types of things really
make a difference in terms of the
the subtlety of
the psyche of what's going on and how
that by osmosis literally can be seen on
screen
and less room for any kind of air
accidents
arguments
all of it all of it it's just it's just
you get all of these
you know
people who could be going in completely
different directions and you get them
all going in the right direction you
know and keeping them in that direction
and when they're not focused being able
to be be the person who's willing to go
in and say focus up whatever that is
because you're not worried about how
they i don't care about how you feel
right now i care about the movie so it's
not about your feelings i'm sorry your
feelings are hurt but it has nothing to
do with that we're all here for the
movie are you here for the same thing
it comes really easy when you got the
same thing
and we're all thinking about the same
thing it's hard to argue it's we're only
arguing for it
we're only advocating for the movie
everything else should become secondary
in a good way
go home see your family take care of
your loved ones don't sacrifice your
life
don't be the perpetual bachelor
cuddle with your cat yeah cuddle with
god whatever get a cat
play tennis go for a run do something
right
what's your favorite film about the film
industry
narrative good question not documented
um narrative there are many and i love
things about it and of course mine
redemption is about the hollywood
industry on some level too but i would
have to say the bad and the beautiful
um just because
i think it speaks so much to me about
what it's like to be
a good person in hollywood and what it's
like to be a bad person in hollywood
and
that it's always been more important to
me
to
be a good person in terms of my
intentions about my art and what i'm
doing it for because why would i what
would be the point so
if that meant i was going to have great
hollywood success as some people thought
i was early or if it just means that i'm
an independent producer who's still
working
which is still the best thing ever then
then that's all it is and i still try to
maintain that because it's like having
humility
and love for
what i'm doing i think is the most
important thing and i think that's
what's keeping me young so i think i'm
going to stick with that one and that
movie teaches me a lot about
all the kind of negative thing the
trappings of producer life
uh and at one point that character kirk
douglas's character is asked and i'm not
exactly quoting it but to have movies
whatever your name is you have to have
humility i mean just the character
simply asks do you have humility
and i would ask do you have
humility enough to sacrifice what you
think for the best of the project
and that's the character asks the kirk
douglas character this yes do you have
humility yeah do you have enough
humility to just be doing it for the
project not for your ego you know that's
you know so as a producer i think that
that's like having as little ego
as possible
is one of the most
most incredible and most important
things that producer you know
the more you can operate that way i
think the better that you'll do
and what is his response as the
character he doesn't answer
because obviously he doesn't have
humility uh he's not the character that
does he's stomped on his best friend
they made a movie together he
can't even get any work anymore you know
he's one of these people that just
really has stepped over body after body
i'm gonna have to go back and watch it
again now
make me want to watch that that puppy